we are starting your journey on The
Bachelorette right now Rachele season
has really switched things up you guys
kind of threw the timeline a little bit
out the window we threw a few you know
monkey wrenches in because we're always
trying to like raise the bar a little
bit and change things up so obviously
the announcement of Rachel but bringing
on the four guys live on after the final
rose was it was just something fun I
mean but really then you stopped taping
and then they had to re-emerge on the
show it was just something fun we did
for the fans we thought it'd be neat to
do it live and I don't even know if it
worked I I thought it was fun but it was
also kind of crazy and hard to produce
but throughout the show you I think
anymore we really don't go into it
thinking we're gonna change things
dramatically because you don't have to
the great thing about this show is you
bring Rachel and you bring these guys in
and the show is gonna be different they
bring their own insecurities their own
issues their own strengths their own
weaknesses and you kind of throw it into
this pot and you get this wild
bachelor/bachelorette gumbo and that's
what comes out and so you know we really
don't go into it thinking how can we
make it different because it will be it
just will be 15 years of TV and three
different primetime series going it just
doesn't happen and especially in this
day and age it just doesn't happen so
all due respect to bachelor nation and
all love to them for keeping us on this
long it is it is awesome how do you see
it looking different in 15 years it
changed a lot from season one to now
obviously the show's evolved and we've
kind of found our formula and what works
and yeah the great thing about is the
show is different every season because
of who's on it but the beauty is at the
end of the day you look at the last
segment of the other finale the proposal
that doesn't change and I think that's
kind of the beauty of the showing the
success lies in that last 10 15 minutes
of its this guy in this girl standing on
a beach or a mountaintop or whatever
just looking at each other hoping
they're scared they're praying it's
going to work out to death that part's
really never changed maybe in the
history of time that hasn't changed you
know at the end of the day you could
have you know all these different social
media all the different dating sites but
it's still just between these two people
that are falling in love
you